I believe the show is going to come in
at uh 8 okay it's going to be yeah I
think it's going to come in at 8 I think
it's going to be highly good but it's
still going to be left up to the
question is walking away from that show
is how does those games feel and I don't
believe that's Indy's face at all I
don't believe so I believe they walk
away from Harrison Ford because the last
movie didn't paint him in a good light
but it was a great Indiana Jones movie
if you're a fan of the series he did get
his prize in that movie so I and I think
we all wanted Indie to always get his
prize so at the end when he's crying
he's like I'm in history that part right
there was really good and he got his
prize